la case zéro gaspille c'est exactement
le contre-pied du black friday et sa
frénésie d'achat sur les stands on
apprend à réparer recyclés et l'on donne
ce dont on ne se sert plus j'en apprends
aussi à faire soi même les produits du
quotidien comme ici les cosmétiques
alors pendant cette phase est la vraie
épaisseur hi-fi dentifrice mais aussi
des eaux d'oran ou crèmes pour la peau
c'est vraiment génial parce que bon
s'amuser à créer quelque chose que qu'on
va essayer c'est une belle découverte
pour moi
au lieu d'acheter voila voila voila je
fais partie du système d'échangé local
donc je suis déjà dans une démarche de
nos gaspillages avec quelques produits
de base comme l'argile et l'huile de
coco fabriquer ses produits tout seul et
la sphère de quelques minutes deux fois
par mois le collectif local life propose
ses ateliers chez l'habitant
on prend des produits naturels donc sans
produits chimiques sans perturbateurs
endocriniens 100 choses qui peuvent être
mauvaises pour notre santé et pour
l'environnement pour la nature donc on
réduit les emballages ont réduit les
produits chimiques et aussi on permet
aux gens d'avoir des cosmétiques qui
sont non plus pas testés sur les animaux
on sent qu'il ya une demande qui est
forte rien que le fait de faire maison
c'est comme quand on cuisine et ses
notes produit c'est nous qui l'avons
fait et du coup rien que ça en fait ça a
son importance
plus loin c'est une ambassadrice de la
cacem qui partage ses recettes de
produits ménages des lessives aux
pastilles pour le lave vaisselle en
passant par le spray pour les vitres on
peut tout faire soi-même à base de
vinaigre blanc savon de marseille ou
noir bicarbonate et cristaux de soude
ce qui fonctionne le mieux c'est la
liste est aussi l'assouplissement
pourquoi parce que c'est plus facile
c'est un peu de vinaigre et de l'huile
essentielle et c'est tout qu'est ce qui
a marché chez vous le nettoyant
dégraissant donc la recette c'est du
vinaigre blanc dans lequel on fait
macérer de l'agrume du zestes d'agrumes
un certain temps et vraiment ça laisse
l'odeur d'agrumes et ça dégraisse très
très bien la cuisine
qu'est ce qui vous motive à la maison
pour faire ça
la consommation passait mieux utiliser
de produits chimiques naturelles surtout
la pratique permettent aussi de réduire
la surutilisation des emballages comme
le plastique chaque année un
martiniquais produites en moyenne plus
d'une demi tonne de déchets